[Musique]
là
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro 17 8 culture au
programme aujourd'hui les lieux
culturels sont dans la tente d'une
potentielle date de réouverture à la mi
mai une éventualité évoquée par le
président de la république emmanuel
macron espoir ou utopie nous avons
interrogé des représentants des lieux
culturels libinois en raison de la crise
sanitaire le métier de george grey a
évolué auteurs et éditeurs il est devenu
marchand le principe se rendre sur des
marchés tout présenté ses bd il sera
avec nous pour parler de son nouveau
métier
et puis cinq monuments yvelinois ont été
inscrits site historique cette année un
statut qui favorise la protection ada
bâtiment du fait de son intérêt
artistique historique ou architectural
nous sommes allés à la découverte de
trois d'entre eux et je vous le disais
en titre les lieux culturels sont dans
l'attenté d'une potentielle date de
réouverture à la mi mai et
d'éventualités évoquée par le président
de la république emmanuel macron dans
son discours du 31 mars
musées théâtres ou encore salles de
spectacles se prépare donc à rouvrir mi
mai ou à devoir attendre la saison
prochaine
des lieux culturels qui ne pourront pas
rouvrir en 48 heures ils ont besoin
d'anticiper une réouverture à la mi mai
se dessine-t-elle ou est-elle utopique
et écouter le maire adjoint de la
culture à elancourt
si on n'est pas capable au minimum je
n'ai vraiment à l'avant vont nous dire
c'est nouveau mais où le 15 mai ou le 20
mai il sera très très compliqué nos
rencontres des engagements et que les
troupes puissent être présentes pour
rendre j'allais vivre une programmation
là où elle était restée ça c'est un
premier sujet avec ses pales topic est
le deuxième sujet c'est connaître les
conditions de la reprise c'est à dire
que si on me dit même maintenant que
c'est le 15 mai mais si on nous dit que
c'est en pensant l'agent de 50 ans d'âge
70 % la jauge
évidemment ce n'est pas la même chose en
raison de la crise sanitaire son métier
a évolué jure je dois vous êtes avec
nous ou dont soir bonsoir
donc vous êtes auteur éditeur est
maintenant un marchand et vous vous
rendez sur des marchés pour présenter
vos bd vos ouvrages et faire des
dédicaces
pourquoi avez vous eu ce besoin de vous
réinventez alors vas-y nécessité parce
que depuis un an je suis un éditeur
indépendant le seul éditeur du sud
yvelines
et la problématique c'est qu'il n'y a
plus de salons du livre et comme les
libraires n'ont plus de trésorerie ben
je pense qu'à moyen et long terme c'est
fini pour nous les indépendants en
librairie donc qu'il fallait trouver une
alternative
il m'était relatives à tous ces manques
et donc je me suis mis marchands
ambulants
donc je vais montrer mes oeuvres et
bizarres que j'ai dit bao locaux puisque
je suis le seul éditeur zilling j'ai
commencé par faire les marchés de
rambouillet de bonnel de dourdan de
s'attarde le mono dans le 28
voilà je le samedi le dimanche matin
on peut me croiser sur les marches et
vous avez d'ailleurs maintenant la carte
des marchés ambulants de marchands
ambulants
ce n'est plus le public il ya un vous
c'est vous qui allez au public
oui mais c'était un peu le principe des
de ce que je faisais habituellement
puisque les salons du livre par là dans
toute la france alors moi mon problème
c'est que je tournée dans toute la
france c'est que la maj et gels me suis
recentré je me suis relevé je disais
toujours à mesure de leur puisque je
suis militant le plus de 100 titres
j'ai toujours beaucoup on est roi tollé
chez soi est roi chez les autres mais
massa se confirmer ça ce que sa firme
puisque maintenant j'ai cédé 3 chez moi
sur votre stand ce sont vos propres bd
que vous présentez qu'est-ce qu'on peut
retrouver en ce moment tout moi ça va de
la petite enfance jusqu'à l'âge adulte
efficiente au il faut savoir je viens de
sortir cinq nouveautés la première -
dessiner des charlots la banda aides que
je vous présente parce que c'est une
petite merveille
c'est la première bande dessinée au
monde avec des héros handicap et j'en
suis très très fier c'est pas de leur
durée que c'est la fierté avec le tome 6
on arrive à atteindre un degré d'humour
de messages et là en l'occurrence ça se
passe à l'hôpital
c'est pour les soignants les aidant les
accompagnants c'est un vrai passé avec
ludisme en surprises à ceux en bande
dessinée
c'est une activité que vous pourriez
peut-être gardé après la crise sanitaire
oui oui oui les salons qui me demande de
l'argent pour pour parler vulgairement
c'est du mètre linéaire
et des fois je sans faire de l'argent je
suis maltraitée en tant qu'éditeur et en
tant qu'auteur donc jeux steam que sont
les marchés
je suis bien traité d'ailleurs on
réclame beaucoup moins d'argent et le
profit est plus grand et puis surtout
s'il ya des rencontres immédiate et
comme je fais des marchés régulièrement
dans les mêmes endroits les mêmes
marchés
mais j'ai des retours de lecture qui
sont fabuleuses plus d'attendre un an
le ca l'an prochain j'attends une
semaine et j'ai ce résultat alors j'ai
sorti un steve healy de la chanson de
pierre perret mise en albums jeunesse
est une petite merveille
et puis j'ai sorti le doudou qui peut
qui fait un carton totalement en en main
sur les marchés et laissez vous aller
marcher ça marche c'est parti c'est
parfait et justement ce moment où est ce
qu'on peut vous retrouvez alors bon
dimanche dans 15 jours je serai au
marché de rambouillet ou marché de
bonnel et ce dimanche
ce week-end j'ai c'est d'être à dourdan
et peut-être à limours si on m'accepte
voilà il a écouté parfait merci beaucoup
je regrette d'avoir été avec nous auteur
et éditeur je rappelle pour graal
édition
[Musique]
cinq nouveaux monuments viennent d'être
inscrits sites historiques dans les
yvelines
un statut qui favorisait la protection
d'une bâtisse du fait de son intérêt
historique artistique ou architectural
bixente merrien santisteva les parties
de découvrir la promotion 2020-2021 dont
les yvelines avec célia 400 go regarder
cette année cinq sites yvelinois se sont
ajoutés à la longue liste des monuments
historiques l'occasion pour nous de vous
faire découvrir deux d'entre eux
première étape de notre périple aigle et
st vincent de paul à villepreux
suivez-moi
[Musique]
c'est la cadette cette édition 2021
l'église saint vincent de paul a été
construite au 20e siècle
achevé en 1967 nous sommes avec if it
est adjoint au maire et président de la
société d'histoire de villepreux donc
monsieur py tête quelle est la
spécificité de cette église la plus
grande spécificité c'est que l'église
est construite encastré entre des
immeubles d'habitation il est donc bien
au coeur de la du quartier qui a été
construit en même temps qu'elle cela a
permis d'avoir cette grande façade qui a
été décoré par robert lisbonne heat qui
a plus grave élevé tout est là on
retrouve un certain nombre d'
inspiration venue de de l'apocalypse et
puis de la vie saint-vincent-de-paul et
aujourd'hui donc cette nomination parmi
les monuments historiques va être
important dans la mesure où cette église
qui a maintenant plus de 50 ans a besoin
d'être soutenue restaurer et c'est un
bâtiment d'encre et s'en est atypique
contrairement à notre deuxième visite le
château privé de vaux sur seine
et
nous sommes donc avec laeticia et dan
grain propriétaire du château construit
à la fin du moyen-âge il est devenu un
lieu symbolique du val de seine avec une
vue imprenable
donc la famille vous êtes la septième
génération de la famille maroc et y qui
était car l'homme a fait tilt
premier propriétaire du château et bien
karl au maroc et y était un scripteur un
sculpteur de renom il a notamment
réalisé le maître d'oeuvre de l'église
de la madeleine à paris cette demeure a
accueilli de nombreuses personnes
célèbres des artistes tels que delacroix
le peintre mais aussi cinq sens le
compositeur donc ça c'est la génération
suivante
en temps normal le château possède une
activité quelle est l'activité voilà en
général de château ouvre le château bien
évidemment au public tout au long de
l'année
que ce soit à travers les journées du
patrimoine mais aussi grâce à l'office
de tourisme de poissy avec lequel nous
avons un partenariat donc qui nous
permet d'accueillir des petits groupes
de visiteurs
à partir de cet été si bien entendu les
conditions nous le permettent
nous souhaitons à pouvoir accueillir
tout type d'événement privé public que
ce soit culturel associatif avec cette
orangerie qui se trouve à l'exacte
emplacements de l'ancienne orangerie
donc en espérant que vous puissiez
reprendre une activité dès cet été
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
madame merci à vue trois autres
monuments ont également été inscrits en
tant que site historique cette année une
seconde église notre dame de la nativité
à mantes la jolie le monument aux morts
de conflans sainte honorine et enfin la
villa verre d'eau à bougival
vous venez donc de l'entendre située à
bougival le papillon est de la villa
viardot et son parc en hauteur sont donc
désormais inscrit au site historique
célia gars de son goût bon soir dans ça
vous êtes là justement pour nous en
parler
alors pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas
encore cette célèbre villa pouvez-vous
déjà nous la présenter oui c'est une des
plus anciennes propriétés de bougival la
villa viardot a été construite en 1830
est acheté par pauline viardot grandes
cantatrices du 19e siècle
son mari louis viardot et ivan
tourgueniev écrivain et en russe
cette maison est désormais inscrite au
titre des monuments historiques vous
l'avez dit un puisqu'elle nécessite
d'être conservés d'un point de vue dans
l'intérêt public
la villa est dégradée est laissé à
l'abandon c'est donc une bonne nouvelle
pour le président du centre européen des
musiques des possibles
très bonne nouvelle le fait que enfin la
ville dont est inscrite aux monuments
historiques
selon absolument extraordinaires de
l'histoire de la musique et de
l'histoire de la pensée soit préservée
restaurer et inclut aujourd'hui aux
monuments historiques
et cette année on fête aussi le
bicentenaire de la naissance de pauline
viardot oui elle est née le 18 juillet
1801 21 à paris malheureusement
l'inauguration de la villa viardot ne se
fera pas lors de ce bicentenaire à cause
de la crise sanitaire
elle sera reportée en 2022 mais l'opéra
comique à paris et dédiera une journée
entièrement à pauline viardot le 6
octobre 2021 et donc la villa va pouvoir
accueillir du public
oui ce lieu de mémoire va s'inscrire
dans un projet de centre européen de
musique il y aura des master class des
concerts des conférences des expositions
qui font partie donc de ce grand projet
qui s'appelle le champ trop plein qui
sont là ont donné 24 et cette villa
va-t-elle reprendre vie comme à l'époque
c'est bien exactement à l'époque
justement le monde culturel et
artistique se donner rendez vous dans
cette propriété
il y a eu à emile zola george sand ou
encore ivan tourgueniev ce dernier
d'ailleurs a connu une relation amicale
et peut être amoureuse ont fait pas avec
pauline viardot il était donc souvent à
bougival
il a d'ailleurs écrit depuis la villa
viardot des lettres avec gustave
flaubert que vous pouvez retrouver dans
ce livre je n'ai pas les nerfs assez
robuste pour vivre dans ce monde là
sorti il ya un mois et édité par le
passeur alors merci
c'est la gueule tsongo d'avoir été avec
nous on vous retrouve bien sûr pour le
7-8 week end me mercier et c est la fin
de ce set 8 culture merci de nous avoir
suivis et à bientôt sur t&d 78 et d'ici
là portez vous bien
[Musique]